foreign
let's go to Marie in Stevens Point
Wisconsin what's up Marie
hey Dr Jim thanks uh for having me on
your show of course what's happening
okay so next summer I am getting married
and gross do you like him
yes all right good for you hey I'm
excited for you good for you
thank you so my parents have given the
greatest gift of setting up a whole
mutual fund that's uh specifically going
to be used for the wedding and then
anything left over they said we could
use straight towards our house down
payment
so are you all loping and just taking
all the money and dumping it on your
house
uh no we're having a wedding
um
but
my parents are kind of
insistent that we have like a big
expensive party and we don't really want
that and I'm having a hard time
communicating with them to have us both
be on the same page
all right I'm going to give you my
opinion this doesn't represent the
people I work for this doesn't represent
my wife my family she represents just me
okay
okay is that cool
yeah
if you are accepting their money you're
also accepting what that money is buying
them which is the choice to run your
wedding
I don't like it for you it's it makes me
Oogie
but they have purchased their influence
their opinions their choices on how you
are going to celebrate your marriage
because they're paying for it
and so either
you all can make peace with it
and just say cool y'all are paying for
it let's blow it out
or you can have a really uncomfortable
conversation that goes something like we
value having
um a paid off house more than we have
one big wild party
so we want this to be as small as
possible so that we can put the rest of
the money towards our house and if they
say that's that's are they have they let
me ask have they said like well your
guests are really gonna have they said
that
all right they well they keep going back
and forth saying that they had a small
wedding and so we're allowed to have
whatever we want and that the day is
about the two of us so we get uh make
all the decisions and then when we tell
them something they say that's tacky and
we shouldn't be skipping out our guests
because they have to travel and like pay
for their hotel so we should be I love
it giving them the best dessert or
whatever I love it but then they turn
around and say but it's your wedding so
it's do you guys get to choose
okay just move forward knowing you don't
get a choice
okay not even a little one
um at some point you can sit down with
with
um is this your parents
yes you can sit down with your mom or
dad and say how about this you all
designed the wedding that y'all want to
pay for and we will we will show up and
be ready to party
okay
um
and that will probably be uncomfortable
or they might say oh thank God like what
would they say if you sat down and said
hey we've we've just had an epiphany I
don't want to put any more tacky ideas
in front of you I don't want to put any
more things that you think are going to
be disrespectful to the guests so how
about this you all plan an amazing
wedding y'all are paying for it you play
an amazing wedding and we will be there
and we will we will dance the night away
what would you what would they do if you
said that
um I think they'd be happy about that
but they also don't want to plan the
whole thing either because we've already
like picked out most of the stuff and
now it's just kind of coming down to
like
extra bands and like wedding favors and
what dessert people to go with Ed is the
money worth it
um I mean how much we talking
uh like a hundred okay
how much are you spending on this week I
was gonna see also my Integrity for a
hundred thousand dollars let's be clear
um not really but kind of
how much is this wedding gonna cost
um all right now on my budget sheet it's
like 35
okay
and which part of it are you feeling
uncomfortable with as though it violates
some sort of core principle in you
spending so much money on one day
it's not your money so why does it
bother you
um I don't
I don't know I guess it just seems like
a really big number it's a huge number
is there a part of this that you have an
identity of your of yourself a story you
tell yourself that those type of
weddings are for those type of women
or those type of weddings are for
I'm I'm I'm not that I am
I'm something else there's a great
Theologian that said people can often be
as proud of the things they don't have
as those as other people are of the
things they do have
that's that's a that's a thing I fall
into is that is that what you're
struggling with or is this just purely
like no this is insane this is one night
it's not worth thirty five thousand
dollars
it's a mix of both okay it's definitely
both
okay
because I don't want to paint your
picture your parents in a bad light it
sounds like they're they're willing to
put
55 or 65 000 down on your house for you
which by the way they're gonna have an
opinion about which house you buy and
where you buy it and what kind of the
decorations you have in your house and
what's Tech you're not there comes a
moment in your young marriage and you
have to decide they've got a lot of
money and we don't want it
or I'm just trying to decide like where
do I put my what down on this
where do you want to put it down
because the uh the house buying process
will be exactly the same
and then when they start a college fund
for your first child it will be the
exact same
this is for wherever he or she wants to
go to college if whatever well he wants
to actually go to a trade school well
yeah this is we this scene he's go
Stanford
right this is gonna happen Forever This
has probably happened your whole life is
that fair
yeah yeah
and so you eat I mean the two choices
before you that I could see is you make
peace with it or you say no thank you
all right what do you what are you gonna
do
foreign
relationship with my parents so but I
see here's where that's oh Marie don't
do that don't do that don't do that you
know what you just did
you took their relational dysfunction
and made it your job to fix it
I don't want to have a bad relationship
with them so I guess I will fill in the
blank just take their money or I'll just
have the wedding they want me to have or
I'll just buy whatever house they tell
me I need to buy or I'll just
start from the from the completely other
end for the first time in your life
Marie you've never done this for the
first time do it
say what kind of Life do I want to have
what kind of Life do I want to have
what is important to me and my fiance
what kind of home do we want to have
what kind of party do we want to have
celebrating our marriage
and if that means a low-key party that
has really expensive desserts all right
or no it's a big deal to me that we
don't have expensive desserts I want to
donate that money to a local uh Food
Bank Great tell your parents
but don't do things don't continue to
come you've been doing this your whole
life
and now you're making a new home this is
what family tree changing family tree
looks like
I'm not going to use my money to get to
to buy influence over my kids lives I'm
gonna love them unconditionally
see what I'm saying
is that some bonkers
no
is this not even possible like something
you're even interested in or not really
I mean it's um I mean it sounds possible
you don't sound like it one bit
I'm just like scared to talk to them
here's your homework assignment you
ready
yes okay tonight I want you to sit down
um with a piece of paper
not on a computer either with a piece of
paper you know what I don't care if it's
on a computer I don't care just on your
cell phone
and I want you to
write down for the first time my dream
wedding here's what it would look like
and I want you to write down my dream
home here's what it would look like
and then in the next 48 to 72 hours I
want you to take your fiance out for
some sort of meal
with a blank sheet of paper and I want
you to say hey we're building a new
world together a new life
what do we want this to look like
I want you to be super specific we want
to have a home like this in this
neighborhood and we want to have this
many kids and of course all this will
change
but you're practicing something you've
never done which is asking yourself what
do I actually want
because right now you're a puppet for
your parents fantasy and I'm not
painting them in a bad light they've
done really well for themselves
financially they've planned ahead
and they've planned ahead with the
purpose of our kids we'll have weddings
that look like this and our kids will
have homes that look like that
our kids will drive cars that look like
this our kids will have
their own children our grandkids that
will go to schools like this and what
you are is a pawn in somebody else's
life
and man being a pawn in somebody else's
life with that kind of resources you get
to drive nice cars and your kids get to
uh
go to cool schools and go on great
family vacations
and you also got in the backyard with a
shovel and dig a deep hole and bury
yourself in the process
I don't think it has to be either or I
think there can be a great conversation
about hey Bunch I'll go ahead and just
decide what we're having for dessert
because it seems to be really important
to you and it's not to us
or hey we've just had a long hard
conversation and we're gonna just return
the money and we're gonna figure it out
on our own because we want to have our
kind of wedding we want to have our kind
of home and I think it's important that
we start from scratch here put that into
a college fund for the grandkids and um
maybe uh maybe they'll use that one day
or just make peace man just get the
fancy desserts
and move on with your day get a couple
of get like 40 or 50 bags of beef and
Cheddars from Arby's
or Whoppers with cheese that would be
incredible what a flex that would be
like here's your fancy desserts and
there's the Arby's and Burger King table
that would be dope actually it's
called compromise right thank you for
the call